LCP arrive sur Youtube
en janvier 2020,
dans le cadre d’une stratégie
de l’entreprise qui est
d’entrer dans le média global.
L’arrivée de LCP sur Youtube,
ça permet, je pense,
de dépoussiérer
et de désinstitutionnaliser
la chaîne et l’entité.
C’est le premier réseau
de vidéos au monde,
et donc c’est une audience
à la fois jeune et à la fois énorme.
" Oh bonjour Madame!
Non, c’est pour une émission pour LCP.
Ça s’appelle «Dé-con-fi-nés»."
Le fait d’être sur Youtube permet,
contrairement à ce que l’on pense,
de pouvoir diffuser des programmes
qui sont plutôt longs,
et des programmes
en avant-première par exemple.
" - T’es fière parce qu’elle va à Henri IV?
Ou parce qu’elle est bonne à l’école?
- Elle est bonne à l’école
et en plus...
- Ah, c’est parce que
c’est un grand lycée…
Ben oui, nous on n’a pas pu donc
c’est sûr, tu es la génération
qui réalise les rêves. "
On a des documentaires quand on a
des documentaires en co-production
et qu’on souhaite mettre en avant.
On a un magazine qui s’appelle
«Les Grands Entretiens»
porté par Guy Lagache.
" - Bonjour Xavier Niel!
- Bonjour. "
Le programme a tout de suite
très bien marché sur Youtube,
mais en plus, ce qui a d’assez intéressant,
c’est que Xavier Niel a avoué
que dans sa jeunesse,
il avait travaillé pour la DGSE.
" - Je ne suis pas dans les services secrets,
je suis un honorable correspondant
je ne sais pas comment on appelle ça.
- Des services secrets?
- Voilà.
A qui on dit régulièrement,
voilà ce qui se passe
dans notre univers du piratage. "
Cette information-là a été reprise
par un journal anglais.
Et dès que l’information a été
publiée par ce journal anglais,
l’audience a été doublée.
On a refait notre site.
On est plus présents
sur les réseaux sociaux.
On est maintenant sur Youtube,
voilà, ça va en tout cas permettre
de moderniser un peu l’image de la chaîne
et aussi, je pense,
de rajeunir un peu l’audience.